it was up I was the Bonnie welcome to my
Cosmo cover shoot
when bonnie is a lady in goals on the
September issue of Cosmopolitan and
she's revealing even more about her
divorce from Gavin Rossdale she tells
the mag only a handful of people
actually know the specifics of what
happened between her and Gavin but hints
at just how bad things got quote nobody
would believe it if I could really say
what happened I went through months and
months of torture
Gavin allegedly had an affair with a
couples nanny and the 46 year old is
asked whether she knew something was
going on quote all you have to do is
listen to every single song I've ever
written and it's all there it's an
ongoing theme that I've had for a long
time nearly a year after her split from
Gavin Gwen is going strong with Blake
Shelton he talks about writing with him
something she says she never did with
Gavin and says their mutual trust issues
helped bring them together I just so
badly wanted to make something good out
of something bad